[Musica]
silenzio
che
si era
bella ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi siamo
tutti un brivido siete stanchi di esse
etero beh questa qui è la puntata che fa
per voi enrico the predator sono entrati
con la [ __ ] stampata in fronte e
usciranno pronti per fare il loro primo
bocchino
[Musica]
oggi devo fare un unico ora frappuccino
è uno delle domande forse più
omosessuali che siano mai state
concepite dal nostro signore questo qui
è un inno
all'amore universale
mi raccomando ragazzi un'avvertenza
soltanto questa qui è una ricetta
perfetta per fare le foto ma occhio
occhio perché in due secondi vi trovate
al 90 all'interno di un autogrill a che
cosa facciamo andiamo per prima cosa a
creare la base di questo pipitone cioè
costa 6 cucina noi unicorno frappuccino
bucci quanto dovevo dire regioni con fra
peggiori che non diventi fa
scaldiamo l'acqua perché andiamo a fare
a bagno mariah carrey e di cosa la
canzone mariah carey per quella del
natale la
virtuale e più gay di tel allora io con
la musica non potrò mai essere fatto gay
ha
conosciuto con le note
allora
di cioccolato mette di buon umore
cioccolato
cioccolato però e ricorda che il piano c
a [ __ ] bravissimo romani è che cosa
vedete dei testicoli bravo tu cosa vedi
bravo gay
che pensa subito bene con dei 2 a 1 che
vorrei bari un cielo di perle e pagherei
che mi vengono in
aiuto
che
abita
mamma mia omosessualità in coro non so
perché oggi siamo svegliati così i
ragazzi anzi se siete gay scrivetelo qua
sotto
diventate sempre siete di aver
commentato e qua sotto
mi ricorda lo sperma oppure
gay o perché erano spera ma rai a questo
punto prendiamo un po di acqua la
mettiamo qua prendiamo il blu
dei
ragazzi io vado lì me
è lo so non me ne frega niente ricotta
voi siete pronti davvero a vedere i
ragazzi momento porno
porno
ok ragazzi guardate che bello guardate
che cosa ti fa pensare sala caduta mg
kabul
ok questo è fatto ragazzi ho bisogno di
fare entrare in campo adesso un ottimo
tritatutto
[Musica]
benissimo così sica
calcinato gelato gelato gelato al
cioccolato
oggi possiamo a dormine
allora aggiungo a questo punto il frate
mago harry è una ricetta poi noi si fa
occhio alle stazioni ho visto dandole
delle dosi tra dove che a un certo punto
che i trader che effettivamente quello
che dobbiamo fare rete vedrete vedrai
guarda guarda con i pezzetti occhi vedrà
vedrai vedrai vedrai che altro ghiaccio
lirico
merito
centro di pecchia nimmo tutte le canzoni
catene hanno tutte altre parole perché
come risentite
giorni
ma io mi sa che ci caremani cazzo
[Musica]
ovvio sembra di sera ragazzi io direi di
aggiungere sarà la caduta ng capo nulla
aggiunge un po di rosa anche tu rosa blu
dipinto di blu ma tutti
svaniscono perché un po di sciroppo
d'acero un po ragazzi di succo di limone
da adesso sei è vero con il più gretto e
fucka limite ok
[Musica]
sapevo di essere un
tirannosauro
mamma mia non parla c'è una donna
io questa faccia una sera a 500 ml nord
su caricato un anno 500 ml hai capito il
gioco era un fatto di scenico ieri ora
sto facendo esserlo nella loro si sono
contese lo fa in scemi perché sono un po
indietro rosicano ad occhi ad hoc i
[Musica]
ragazzi prendiamo dove di qui
divertiamoci ragazzi quindi mi
raccomando blu no fear o blu
un minimo di
mistero
vi ricorda qualcosa
tocco finale alla casse
[Applauso]
libero solamente una cosa
vuole
ma secondo me lo sciroppo d'acero c'è
stata la merda è più buono senza perché
fa più fra per come ce con lo sciroppo
d'acero
questa sensazione di dolciastro
ragazze possono in rosa è una merda
è bello ma certo viper che hanno tutto
con il cioccolato per fare una merda
rimaniamo
sin dall'inizio
l'aver patto posso dirlo a frappè allora
un frappè al fior di latte che era più
dignitoso con semplicemente un pochino
di cacao o colorato cioccolato fuso
colorato così questa ricetta è troppo
una donna ma sempre bei ragazzi
ragazzi detto ciò se lo farete una cosa
carina da fare per fini capitale delle
figlie dell'indice si divertono quei
colori che si bevono questo cosino per
merenda o per un compleanno per una
festa che volete fare tu spicci a casa
in due secondi
vedi togliete are caso e penso che state
pure bravi genitori
per il resto
la mezza soda ok ecco il cuore che lo
dico come sempre noi comunque ci vediamo
domenica prossima sempre alle 12 con un
nuovo cucina ciao
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]